what would happen if Karl Marx rose from
the dead and woke up in modern-day
London would he recognize the city where
he lived in exile it may be a dream
destination for well-heeled tourists but
with all its luxury shops and flats it's
a nightmare for the working classes
could Marx afford to live in the inner
city absolutely not
he'd likely wind up sleeping in a phone
booth so what would Marx have to say
today exploitation commodity fetishism
and the power of money which of his
theories are still relevant
at Piccadilly Circus I meet marks
researcher Lucia prod Ella
she came to London a decade ago to study
Marx's writings in the libraries where
he once read and conducted research
pradilla takes us on a walking tour
through Soho the area where Marx once
lived
our first stop perform a Red Lion pub
birthplace of a communist manifesto
today it's a cocktail lounge what marks
be shocked surely he would be surprised
to see Soho today because at this time
it was really different it was a very
poor area and a lot of German and other
European refugees actually lived the
year but I don't think it would be
surprised to see capitalism today I
think that actually he predicted many of
the processes that we are witnessing
today from you know the kind of
globalization of a production and trade
in crack increasing migration and
internationalization not only of capital
bottles of the working-class Karl Marx
himself has become a product marketed
around the globe there's even a hair
salon in Chinatown named after him well
I guess even philosophers have to get a
haircut sometimes
this is Dean Street where Marx lived
with his wife Jenny and their children
in a two-room flat they barely had
enough money for rent and food three of
their children died during their time in
Soho Marx knew about the daily struggle
for survival in his day people were
literally work to death in factories
that still happens today in places like
China and Bangladesh but in Europe too
exploitation remains common and has got
worse in the wake of the economic crisis
the crisis has led to increasing
exploitation because one of the effects
of the crisis hasn't been just like
cutting on social services law lowering
wages and so on but also lengthening of
the working time working hours the
number of people that work more than 48
hours a week has increased by millions
yes after the crisis when we talk about
exploitation we have to talk about
working conditions of Chinese workers
and Bangladesh seamstresses if we look
at the struggles of workers at Foxconn
in China who protested against the
inhuman conditions in the factories they
actually kind of make these relations
that are behind our commodities visible
but if we go to an Apple store here
probably people in retail are also low
paid overworked
so the awareness can actually link
together people from different parts of
the world I don't think it's something
that concerns all only countries in the
South I think it's a kind of globalized
experience that actually marks a
predicted
lucha pradilla believes in a communist
ideal of international solidarity and
the power of the collective but are we
really ready to do without to consume
less so others have more from life I'm
on my way to the south of London to meet
Nina power she's a renowned expert on
Marx and a staunch feminist what would
Marx have to say about the gender pay
gap and gender inequality why are men
still paid more than women for the same
work patriarchy and capitalism is a very
you know happy fit they love each other
and actually what capitalism does is to
reinforce the differences between men
and women and to treat women as property
on the basis of their capacity to
reproduce and both angles and Marx
recognized this let's take a look into
the future world where there's
artificial intelligence doing alienated
labor for us could it be there there
won't be such a thing as a working class
anymore we are not yet at a point at
which we would say that robots can look
after our babies or that we should be
like employing robots to take care of
our older people's loneliness you know
they have trialed these things in parts
of the world like sofa in Japan for
example there might be a distraction but
there are no replacement for human
contact on the one hand I'd be quite
happy if women and men didn't have to
sell sex and if we could replace it with
sex robots or something like that and if
you could generate an AI that you know
did the job like that would be better in
the sense that fewer human beings would
be treated
but at the same time I'm not sure this
is like what we should be aiming for if
it can help us be more together and more
and more solidarity and help each other
fine
but otherwise no interesting Karl Marx
lies buried in Highgate Cemetery
Marx is dead long live Marx we need
visionary thinkers like him more than
ever as the problems of exploitation
poverty and inequality remain unsolved
Karl Marx outlined a vision of a better
world but it's up to us to create it
[Music]